conversations
i just have extra stuff in my car
because it's like so annoying to go all
the way home every time
leave
so if you had to build something out of
everything in your car what could you
build
um
[Music]
testing hello
yeah
is your mic near ac
um let us know how the audio is
hello so what do you think about the
austin comedy scene and how it's a
totally new scene that's never been seen
before in the history of the world
um i think it's uh it's a really cool
scene because there's a lot going on all
the time
and
uh basically like my home scene was so
small compared to this one
like
you just get to see like
yeah like there's just like a lot of
talent here and it's like
it's it's almost it's harder to get seen
but that's a good thing because that
means like you're actually like
surrounded by people that are that
you're impressed by or you're like
they're doing
what you want to be doing
yeah
this place is like a magnet because
everyone comes here
from all over the world
and we all decided we're all meeting
here
yeah this it is like a cool like
i'm like i'm glad i chose this city
because i was between here in new york
and like
new york was just the cost of living was
too much and they still had a lot of
copic restrictions because i was looking
to move last spring
so i didn't want to wait until all the
cobian stuff was lifted so
i chose this city this is actually
april 5th will be one year since i
first visited
austin yeah i remember that you went to
uh
the mic at the park oh yeah i was drunk
during that night can you tell oh
i went there
um
auditorium shores i went to lambert's
while i was waiting for um
for the mic to start after i signed up
and i just like started drinking by
myself and
by the time i left that place i was just
like i didn't even drink that much i
think i like drink but like i felt it
i like when i was like whoa
what happened
yeah i mean probably because
awesome that uh
you were uh going through a
transitionary period and you were here
and you're just like checking it out
[Music]
yeah well i had the trip books before
i was like he was supposed to go
originally and then he was like oh i
kissed my work won't let me go
and i was a
huge [ __ ] about that
you were being a female dog about that
yeah i was like
i was like well if you wanted this bad
enough if you wanted as bad as i would
you would find a way to go with me yeah
he wasn't about that austin life he's
probably like [ __ ] love that like
[ __ ] you know he i don't know what
he's doing i don't really we don't talk
anymore
but yeah moved here and
here i am
yeah i mean a lot of people don't have
the gumption and the uh courage to move
to austin
those people you know they're
they're not they're less for that
they're not fully human like us
no i'm just kidding um i mean it's sad
that you broke up and
it's sad when you plan something to do
together and then someone cancels
because of work like who gives a [ __ ]
the job doesn't care about you the job
is just a faceless entity that
consumes
human beings for profit
and to sacrifice your actual life for a
job and whatever is [ __ ]
i think he just didn't really have as
much interest i think the drop thing was
just kind of like a
like a get off the hook kind of thing
right
no we're just we're just going separate
ways like he was getting more into like
that's pretty sunset look at that
he was getting really into like um
youtube content i was getting more into
like live performance
so once you started kind of like
not
sorry
[Music]
it'll tell you like to stay on i-35
yeah i think we're fine
but once he started like kind of not
showing as much interest and like
drive towards stand up i was kind of
losing interest because that was but
like that's the whole reason we got
together was
because we both loved stand up so
it kind of like created a rift
so his
disinterest in stand-up comedy was like
problematic to create yeah it was it was
definitely one of the things
i mean can't you date someone who's not
a comedian
i i haven't dated since i've been a
comic i've only dated comics which i'm
not sure is a good thing or a bad thing
but
i feel like
i feel like the thing that's good about
it is one they understand what you're
doing they care about it as much as you
do
and they don't care they understand that
when you say like oh i'm gonna be out of
this late mic
i'm gonna be out until like one in the
morning or like you know midnight i'm
gonna be hanging out with all these it's
like it's mostly men so like i feel like
it would be a lot to like
to date a guy that's not a comic and be
like oh by the way i'm gonna be at this
place hanging out with all these men for
hours
most places mostly men
i don't know i've never dated a
non-comic so i guess i can't really say
like what it would be like well i don't
think it's bad i love dating people that
are similar and
going through something together yeah
exactly i mean like i wasn't
expecting like i was expecting this to
happen
like we were just really good we were as
friends
when uh when i moved down here and then
we just slowly started like getting like
to know each other more
developed feelings
but
i wasn't really expecting that to happen
i wasn't like looking for it
i didn't want to take another comic
because
always
you know i just i was like no i don't i
want i wanted to date outside of my
friend group i was like i need to stop
trying to date within my friend group
like this isn't healthy this isn't good
for me and then i tried and it just like
it just wasn't they weren't friendly
i i just wasn't having any luck like i i
don't know i just like
i guess i didn't try hard finding out
they were your friends
you just said they were in your friend
group you just didn't know them well
like i don't know because like
i do the thing i do this thing where i
like i become good friends with a guy
and then
you know eventually
i'm like oh could i see myself with this
person or am i just like
like is this just like a comfort person
because i already know them a lot and
like i already like don't have to go
through like the
the scary part of like going on dates
and doing getting to know somebody and
all that like i already know like
because to me it's like
after a while it started to not make any
sense it's like why am i trying so hard
to like talk to people outside of my
friend group when
me and this person already have a great
connection we already know each other on
like a
we know each other more personal level
we like it just doesn't afterwards
didn't make sense i was like
why is it what's wrong with it i think
some people look at dating as like a
very
uh you know separate like atomized thing
it's like there's my normal life and
this is my dating life and this is my
work life but i don't think that's
natural or healthy i think
in actuality we should be
in this giant mess of uh people and just
like
connecting and
uh you know
being with people in a general sense
instead of just being like okay now let
me go into the dating section of my life
and then i'll let's go to this
part and then oh the comedy part in the
workbook i think it's better if you're
just like oh this is just a person and
let me connect with them and then see
where it goes instead of yeah exactly
like
that's why i hate dating apps because
it's like
now i'm dating it's like it's i don't
know i don't i've never had good luck
with them i've never had like even even
people that seemed like really good and
like in text conversation or in pictures
or in like what they did what they were
interested in if they seem really good
on paper like it's just really hard to
like
meet up with somebody in that context
and have like chemistry like i just
didn't i didn't feel i went on a hitch
day like when um
when jesse was on tour and i just like
didn't i didn't have any chemistry i was
also i just had mouth surgery and i was
like wasn't allowed to drink so i had to
be completely sober for the day so like
that could have also played into it but
drink alcohol you can drink water i
couldn't drink anything with a straw and
i couldn't drink alcohol so i was
literally like in my like i i was
literally like two hours out of surgery
like my like i was like chewing on gauze
during this day it was like really bad
and um
and then we met up we went to did you do
that why didn't you just be like can we
reschedule i just had because
uh because jesse was getting home the
next day
and i kind of figured it was gonna be
now or never like i was like i guess i
could have gone on the date like we
weren't together yet but i felt weird
about it so i was like i would rather do
this while he's on tour just to like
i'd rather just do it now maybe it had
nothing to do with how weird it was
maybe it's just because you guys are
like oh we're gonna
forage an intimate connection now
yeah
there's just like there's no
i think that's the thing about it
there's no reason there's nothing that
brought us together
other than this app other than this one
like
other than ours deciding like okay i
need to date somebody oh there it is
like
any and the weird thing is we had a lot
in common that was the weirdest thing
like we were talking about like scuba
diving you're talking about like
um what else there was something weird
that he was interested in that i was
like oh i was worried that you're
interested in that
because i am too but then but it was
just still no not mayonnaise
but we also we went to this loud piano
bar on like fifth street the reason we
couldn't reschedule is because we bought
tickets to see
taylor tomlinson
so we couldn't reschedule because of
that
um because the tickets are expensive
i was i had put off that surgery for so
long that if i put it off for any longer
i was gonna be in extreme pain
it was just it was just not meant to be
and he didn't even kiss me goodbye and
he didn't text me after saying like oh i
had a good time or just nothing
so clearly he didn't have a good time he
was put off by the dogs i didn't have
the gauze in my mouth during the date i
had it on on the way over and then
i took it out you just had gauze in your
purse
i was just like popping like [ __ ]
ibuprofen and just like hey nice to meet
you
yeah um
maybe
he didn't think that he wanted a kiss
he probably didn't i didn't make a joke
about drooling into soup on the date
that i thought was funny but he probably
did he seemed like he seemed like he was
really funny like when we were talking
in the text he was like oh we would like
kind of go have a little back and forth
going and i was like oh okay this isn't
you know
this is
this is fun
but it was never like
it was always like
whenever i was like talking to somebody
on an app or like trying to do that i
always felt like i was trying to do it
so i could would stop like thinking
about jesse and like stop being like oh
well in case that doesn't happen i need
like i need like
i need to like move on it was never like
it was kind of like i i was forcing
myself to go on dates like i was like oh
you need a comparison like you gotta
you gotta put yourself out there
so i feel like i also like went into it
with like
a bias so i probably wasn't like the
most
dressy
presence of jesse on the day he could
probably sense the fact that i was like
thinking about somebody else or
something i probably wasn't like enough
like
showing him enough like interest
well i think dating is fun and important
and
you know it's a
big part of everyone's development and
like a big part of your life our lives
and
i think like if i'm not dating someone
i'm like less uh comfortable and less
happy and
there's i'm not definitely i'm not nice
to someone every day like if i'm nice to
someone every day it just puts me in a
better mood and
like it gets me practicing talking to
someone
it kind of does like
it definitely like it gives you
something to care about other than
yourself because i feel like when you're
not dating anybody like when i'm not
dating anybody i'm so selfish because
all like all i have to care about is me
yeah what i want to do just only
thinking about yourself like i like
i want i want another person to tell me
like what's going on in their life and
like
yeah i want to be able to help somebody
with something yeah like
we can't always just be thinking about
ourselves we are at our best when we're
thinking about others and the larger
picture
no exactly
but um
yeah i mean maybe this guy was just
it's so weird when you're just like
we're gonna go on a date together
because we both
wanted it really bad
and i think it's better if you're just
like oh hey it's a friend and then let's
uh try to be intimate with uh someone
that i actually know and care about yeah
no it's there's something nicer about
meeting in person and there's something
that you just can't you just can't get
that from
and like i know people that have met
people on apps and they're really happy
with the people i'm not saying that it's
not possible to find love on the apps
but i do think that there's like
there's a cert you just have to have a
certain like
chemistry i just have that
like
i think you're skipping if you just do
the apps they're just skipping a big
part of the
whole thing because they they're
probably just going to work and going to
a gym and going back home they have no
social group they have no friends and
then you're just trying to get the
ultimate intimate most intimate
connection right away well also like
people that don't live in like
so like places with like a big social
scene like it's a lot harder to meet i
think i think the apps have a purpose
but i think in like
i don't know in like a big city like
this like you could meet
you meet a lot of new people all the
time
yeah
i think it's hard sometimes to meet
people but
i think you should just be in general
meeting people
all the time and then a couple of them
are going to be attractive to you and
then you should start dating them
instead of just like
only pursuing the
top of the
pyramid in terms of human connection
um have you are you dating anybody right
now yeah i'm seeing a beautiful lady
right now
from where
she's from
riverside
okay how'd you meet her
uh
i was skateboarding and she was like hot
and then i was like
oh does she recognize you yeah that's
cool all right and then she just
messaged me on instagram and then we
talked and then i didn't talk to her for
a while and then she was like i'm trying
to get it to kill tony and then i was
like yeah come through
and then we uh
we hung out like for the whole kill tony
and then we really hit it off and danced
that's good
yeah so it was a fun meeting you're just
like casually dating you're not like in
a relationship
um we're starting it's only been since
monday so it's only been five days so
you're just kind of talking yeah i mean
i think we've said some pretty heavy
[ __ ] to each other and i think that it's
heading towards a relationship
what does she do
she does she's a sketch comedian oh
that's your sticker
oh nice so it's similar to comedy stand
up but not exactly i do like sketch yeah
sketches it's just sketches yeah she's
super talented so that's another good
finale
what do you mean
i don't mean anything
are you talking about
christie
no what christie
i don't know anything against christie
oh i think she's funny just think that
she's a little wild and
loose cannon sometimes oh for sure but
that's just
that's just the christie you have to
accept and love
oh
that's cool that she's i think it's i
think that's another thing that's like
so important with
someone you're dating is like something
that i i've always
um
valued in like a partner is like
what do i find
not only what do i like find interesting
and admire about you because if it's not
equal it's not gonna work if you're like
obsessed with me or vice versa and i'm
just obsessed with what you're doing
versus being like having my own thing
it's never gonna like if you don't
like if you don't think your partner's
good at something that they like believe
in themselves
with it's hard to like support them when
you don't have the genuine like part to
be like oh
no you're great at that like that's why
i like
i like dating comics that one i think
are funny and like two have a good work
ethic because then i'm like okay well i
if i can respect your like
like
we're both on the same you got to be on
the same level as what i'm trying to say
like you're saying that she's a singer
and sketch artist so obviously you guys
are both like
funny and good at writing and good like
yes
yeah they're like not
talented then it'd be like
you would just have to ignore that or
just be like i'm gonna put up with it
just so that i could be in a
relationship with someone
yeah i don't think that's very healthy
no no it never works it always creates
like uh
but what about like someone who's a
superstar and they have like
a trophy wife or like
someone who's like a support like
who isn't the main star but wants to
support like doesn't do anything
artistic but it's still like
you know like a traditional housewife no
i guess that's just what not what i want
like i don't want to be
i don't want to be a
like
wiping my boyfriend's ass
while he like
wins the world series
that's what they do right
yeah those baseball players are always
getting their ass swept
yeah i mean i get i guess if that's we
if that's what you want if that's what
you're looking for
it's just not i'm just saying that for
myself like that's just something
important to me is like i want i want to
respect what it is
whatever you're doing i want to be like
oh this is good
and i want to genuinely mean it and not
say it just because i like you like i
want to be like oh you're actually
really talented but if someone was
really talented but they were like a
nazi or like they were like
you know like using their talents for
like
how would you be inside
how do you use your
comedic talented starting now what
if like they were doing
stuff that was good but like good art
but it was like morally bankrupt well
then we wouldn't have the same values so
it won't work
okay
i uh
i think that
really we should be making love with
the world and humanity
and consciousness and life
and beauty and order in the universe and
just another person is a convenient way
to do that
but really like what we love is people
and
to have one person that you can show all
that love to is convenient and like a
good manifestation of that
but i think uh deep down we uh really
just
want to be a part of
humanity and show love for humanity
i like that
anyways i think dating is fun but uh you
know it's not the end i'll be all
uh so we're going down to san antonio to
do a show at jokesters pub and gruff
so come out if you're in san antonio at
nine
we're going to be there at 8 30
apparently is that when the show starts
at nine yeah
okay
um have you been to san diego
i have i did blind tiger and um i went
down there with jason in um
on uh
yeah in february
miss tyler you were jason rodriguez
oh probably jason i'm five two so
everybody saw it
jason's pretty small
is he was he like five four five five
yeah maybe even five three he's a big
personality
[Music]
i'm
jason
kidding
no that's cool you guys probably saved a
lot of gas so we drove we drove down
there we did the show and then we drove
straight back and then we uh
i'm excited to stay in san antonio
[Music]
i meant like is it near us where we're
staying
i don't even know where we're staying
oh so you don't even know if it's near
the venue it's near the venue but oh
we're staying at my friend's house so
but uh yeah i mean
i love
san antonio i heard it's a little more
texas than austin so i've got a lot more
toughness i think it's a military town
my grandfather really wants me to see
the elbow
i don't know
every time
kiddo
that doesn't no he's not british
accurate
[Music]
oh i'm so old
he sounds like this
hallie i think that i gotta say
it means a lot to certain people
i just don't see
how
the underdog story really
plays itself out when it's so clear that
america was going to win it just seemed
so obvious that we were going to win
maybe
because alamo was like the sport
and then
americans were trying to take over this
land until they
were in there and then the mexicans were
like this is our land and then they
oh so it was a fight against the
mexicans yeah
hey
it's like do we really have to celebrate
our victory over the mexicans we already
won so hard i feel like
i don't think we were the under were we
the underdogs at that point well in that
particular battle
i don't think in the war we were but in
that battle
america was the americans were
surrounded
here comes a dumb question what war was
that
um
i think it was just general just like i
don't think it was like a war i think it
was just like this
maybe it was the mexican-american war so
that was when we is that when we got
texas yeah
[Music]
i mean they did fight for this land the
command chains were here
they were
hard to deal with we don't need to go
into that history it's sad
[Music]
but it was how funny the sky is are you
seeing the sky right now it's the
beautiful sky
everything has to be
[Music]
so what do you think about the out what
is your grandfather thing about the
alamo
uh he just wants me to see it
i don't know
he just
wants me to
my grandfather was in i think he was in
the caribbean
yeah i think he was in the no he's in
the cuban i think he's in the cuban
missile crisis
he wasn't in vietnam
it was in the cuban missile crisis
i think so i was in the air force
i forget what he was in he was in
something
okay i also forgot what branch so he's a
military man he was
[Music]
my great-grandfather was a world war
ii that was a good one
yeah it's been a long day
japan or europe
i have no idea and he is long gone
well we'll never know
rest
miss congeniality
no
[Music]
so what do you think about
your ultimate tv show like what kind of
stuff would you do
ultimate tv show yeah like
if i was gonna create a show yeah let me
see
like a
like a live show or like uh
just like any show like a drama like a
script
yeah
that's what i'm asking you is what would
you do like a prank show or like a drama
or like a sitcom or like uh i think
either a drama sitcom or animation
um as always that was one of my
dream careers when i was in i think i
was in high school and college was uh
working in a writer's room
you wanted to be uh riffing and throwing
out jokes yeah i wanted to like write
scripts and stuff be like a
screenwriter why
i like to write i like to
why you still like writing like
creating characters and stuff
[Music]
that's cool i wanted to like create a
world
but i mean
i never really wanted to be on a
writer's room
but i would love to create something
with people that i thought was more
talented
yeah
i want to meet i want to meet this girl
this sketch girl
i hope they have good food there
san antonio
we should look up good places to eat in
san antonio
we should ask the locals
true that's what i did when i was in new
orleans
that was the comedy in new orleans it
was fun it was um
everybody every every audience there is
just too way too like
they just make it way too easy for you
because they all just they're all just
already having a good time so just
anything you say just hits
so much harder than it would normally
that's how i describe it you're just
like you're spoiled the crowds out there
spoil you
yeah because they're just like too good
except i did one bar show that was
really low key but i didn't open mic on
friday night and there was this it was
packed so it was a full
it was a full audience it was an open
mic they had like music in between each
comic it felt like a show
and
and the crowd was just so hot like they
were just so
like just so into
the
comedy
that it was just like i did i know i did
all my hits
i didn't really try new stuff because i
wanted to like establish myself in a new
scene
um yeah
so
so i did that and like and then ben went
up after me and then he killed even more
so then the guy that ran the show was
like or the random mic was just like
whoa where did like with these two
comics from austin just like showed up
just
blew the roof off not to be like cocky
but we did really well and then
and then we just left
everyone was like what was that
deal with that
now you know i exist
and i stayed until
i was gonna go home sunday afternoon
this is an eight-hour drive and ben had
to be at work at eight
um
but instead i stayed and did a spot at
this place called the hi-ho lounge
uh on sunday night and it was a great it
was a good show i did i think i had
eight minutes seven minutes
and then um and we got in the car at
like nine we literally didn't get back
until austin until like five in the
morning
but i guess it was worth it because we
got a lot of good stage time
it was a fun it was a fun trip
yeah i love going to a new scene
i think like doing your old material
really well is a skill that it is hard
to work on unless you travel a lot or do
shows a lot
and i think like a lot of open micros
don't appreciate it
they think it's
not as creative but it is uh
the rewards are higher it doesn't matter
if you can write a great
you know like a great mediocre joke
every day
it's like if you have like a solid five
minutes
ten minutes
and you practice that over and over
again to the point where it's you know
unstoppable that's like
that's way better than having like no
exactly and you also you get to see
what's universally funny or what's
relatable in a whole new place with a
whole new culture and like when you get
used to saying it funny way you're like
how do i make this funny each time
can you find the funniest way to say it
and then you say that
and also like everybody on your
everybody here has heard it all before
so it's not like you're not getting i'm
not getting as good feedback
but there it's brand new they've never
heard it so it kind of like
shows me what the joke looks like in a
vacuum when i'm not in a room with
people who aren't even paying attention
or have already heard it and i'm like oh
maybe this joke is like
really
like
is is actually holds up
yeah
i think that's important to do
yeah 100
no definitely have like
it's important to find out which one of
your jokes is the best
and be able to trot it out when you have
to kill really hard what do you mean
trot it out like drag like make the joke
longer oh just bring
choose which jokes you're gonna do oh
yeah yeah do you um
do you listen back to your sets and like
mark which jokes are like the funniest
or whatever
like you get the most laughs you don't
do that no i just have a general sense
and a feeling towards them that changes
every time i do it
yes
it's like if i feel like this joke is
good then
because i actually like doing that i
don't think it's a waste of time maybe
it is but i'll like always sit down and
like type out all the jokes i did in a
set and then be like okay this guy this
got a small laugh that's got a big lap
and then i'll go through it and like
look at
how much this was set like do you do
that for every set yeah so then i go
back and look like okay which joke is
repeatedly repeatedly getting the
biggest laugh which joke is repeatedly
not getting anything and then i kind of
like look for patterns like okay this
joke clearly there's something about
this joke that even like a dead room it
got a laugh versus like
you know like i kind of just
um
i try to do it that way i used to write
my scripts i used to write them out word
for word i used to transcribe my entire
set but i got to a point where i was
just like i can't i can't keep up
there's too many so now i just kind of
like outline them and i'll just like
i'll type out like
keywords and stuff that i'm like oh i
like this phrase or i like this word but
i don't i try not to type out the entire
thing if i don't have to because it's
like i'm just burning myself out for no
reason yeah it's a lot of mental energy
to memorize that word for word
well it's not even like i'm trying to
memorize it it's just like i want us i
want to like pay attention to like oh
was it funnier when i put this word
before this word was it funnier yeah i
mean i just remember the general things
i have to remember like oh i gotta put
this word last in this joke and i have
to remember not to say this word
until at a certain point or else it's
gonna ruin the punchline
okay so you take a more like so what do
you think is the most important thing
um about being good at comedy do you
think it's stage time
yeah i mean i think it's
love for the audience love for yourself
love for
um
humanity
because if you hate the audience you're
gonna go out there without you [ __ ]
i know i don't think i
i ever [ __ ] on the audience that much
um yeah i mean sometimes they deserve it
i got some of the shitty open mics
it's
like depressing and the audi the comics
and slash audience are trying to hurt
your feelings
and they're like purposely trying to
[ __ ] with your head so at that point
sometimes important to lash out i don't
they don't get ugly i don't give that
much of a [ __ ] what other comics think
of my material because a lot of it's
like i'm not a comics comic and i've
just accepted that
don't say that everyone loves you no
thanks
but like
i just mean like i don't
i guess i don't know i guess sometimes i
do comedy for comics but i think i try
to get out of that habits
everyone
tell that oh this is like structurally
sound yeah if you if you like joke
writing then you'll like my jokes but if
you're looking for something that's like
edgy and dirty then you're not gonna
like me at all you're gonna be very
bored
yeah if you like jokes that make fun of
specific things that some people do like
your
your roommate that laughed a certain way
oh yeah
then people are gonna like your jokes
but if they like south alabaster
can we end this podcast
focus
then they're not gonna like your jokes
because we're here your jokes are very
clean and boring yeah they are clean and
boring all right